[Music]
[Music]
well I should begin with saying that
quantum mechanics is the one of the
greatest discoveries of the previous
century it is a marvelous theory that
puts everything in context about the
atoms the molecules and the entire
subatomic world it is all quantum
mechanical but the strange thing about
it is in spite of the fact that it's so
it's so successful in describing the
world that you know it nevertheless
doesn't describe anything it looks like
reality so we are used to working with
this complex situation so if the
equations were being discovered and they
were extremely well but then you ask
what do these equations mean and the
consensus that people in the previous
century reached was that you simply
shouldn't ask you should just calculate
and you get the right answers so why
worry you get the answers that are
observed in any experiment so why worry
and the reason is I think that reality
is very important if you want to have a
theory that sounds more likely to be
true than another theory if the choice
is a theory describes few things as if
they are real as the I or you things
just mixtures of unreal ghost-like
objects then that theory has a much
smaller chance of being correct so I
want to know if the theories you have
today actually describe reality or not
and if not can we cure the disease can
we make a better theory that does this
kind of things as if they are real I say
as if because subatomic particles are so
small and so many of them that you
cannot really describe than the way the
eye that's hopeless but we can't I
discard in the way they could be
and the way they description makes
Dockery sense like it's you talk about
stars and planets you also talk about
stars and pens that you never have seen
but you know that they are there so the
same thing about particles we know that
there are too many of them to keep you
all fight and you say this is real this
is imaginary that's not the way it goes
there all of you but we won't have a
caravel model that described their being
real and this is our difficulty today
that models of cosmic age today don't
even allow us to do that and now it
becomes more serious we do something
wrong so my understanding limited but my
understanding is that that is the
fundamental problem with quantum
mechanics and so for that reason people
are turning to other theories for
describing reality but do you believe
that quantum mechanics can be corrected
in order to describe God hacia is
unknown and so beautiful it shouldn't be
corrected but our interpretation of
congregants should be corrected because
this interpretation is something that
which I find not very desirable it's
hard to say why it has to be wrong but
it's just not Carroll to me I think
besides I like to ask the question you
know is the moon there if nobody looks
analysis of course the more is there
nobody looks what you're talking about
and this is the way our life people also
to talk about elementary particles of
crisis parties are they out of course
this beam of particles that he creates
is a beam of real physical particles and
so on the move this say some of the move
that way we don't know exactly where all
particles go every single one of them
but you know how to go on the average
now quantum mechanics only describes at
average and never goes beyond that well
I think we should try to go beyond that
and say that this is a realistic
scenario of what could be happening
how it could be describing reality well
there's quantum mechanics you know
quantum mechanics it consists of two
parts you see this is basically I
learned from Dirac about the puzzles of
quantum mechanics I think it was partly
because I dozed off at the beginning it
wasn't actually in my mind wandered a
certain point this is his very first
lecture though you see it was right at
the beginning and he was talking about
the superposition principle they see if
you have a particle and if this one
state of the particles it's here another
state of the particle is here then you
can have states where it's here and here
at the same time so you can see
particles can be in two places at once
crazy but that's not quantum mechanic
works then he took a piece of chalk and
I think he broke it in two and said look
the chalk is now imagined it's here and
here at the same time this was the point
my mind wandered you see because he gave
some explanation I think sort of I think
the faintest idea what it was I just
remembered something about the word
energy coming into it and I'm worried
about that ever since you see so why is
it that you don't have pieces of chalk
in two places at once
people in two places at once and all
that and this is a big problem in
quantum mechanics so my view was that
quantum mechanics can't be quite right
and Einstein had that view this is a
little bit more specific because it has
to do with why is it not right but that
took me longer to think about that but
the view is that it can't be quite right
and the way in which it's not quite
right has to be taken advantage of by
the brain so this was the idea that I
had and I wrote this book the emperor's
new mind I thought probably it would
disappear without trace they've been
Stephen Hawking hood
in his book on the brief history of time
and he had got what's his name Carl
Sagan who writer before word so I
thought actually gets done buddy decent
to write a foreword then maybe so I got
Martin Gardner so I I had no idea what
Martin Martin Gardner's views when you
say yes I agree with you he says so he
he was happy to write forward and then I
thought well it's probably won't
disappear without trace know the
difference between the two books is that
beef history of time the Hawking's about
that big and Rogers handy-dandy quick
primer for consciousness about Pathak
it's got pictures thing yes
but it's interesting is this too lot of
people hated it yes they did
oh gosh that I was making a series on
consciousness at the time and again my
whole life has been mentioning you and
people going like this yeah because they
they the criticism was that all rogers
has done is taken a mystery and wrapped
it in enigma and said there you go
taking two things we didn't understand
and say because we don't understand
these two things they must be the same
thing that's not the argument at all
[Laughter]
they haven't read the book no and that's
true it's true but the thing is you see
I had no idea what the answer was so I
wrote the book thinking that by the time
I had to learn some neurophysiology and
that sort of thing by the time I'd love
that bit I would see where there give me
something going on in the brain see the
argument had to be that it had to be
some effect where gravity comes in and I
had no idea at that time it didn't seem
to be no propagation had any chance of
being the answer and the thing is you
see I was hoping that this book would be
read by young people trying to learn
about science and so on most of the
letters I got from people from old
retired people and those were the people
who had time to read the book I guess
but anyway not just old retired people
one person who didn't read the book was
Stuart Hameroff yes Stuart Hameroff his
day job is to put people and maybe in
the night to and it put people to sleep
reversibly in other words give them
general general anesthetics when they
have operations and unlike most of his
colleagues who were just as capable of
putting people to sleep and waking them
up afterwards they didn't seem to worry
as much as he did about what they were
actually doing yeah so this point was
what do the general anesthetics act on
and his view was that they act on these
things called microtubules and so he
sent me a letter and you said the thing
missing from your argument is you
haven't mentioned microtubules and I
thought microtubules I get lots of
letters from lots nutty people you see
oh gosh it's another one but then I
looked it up and I saw the yeah they're
real I should know I should have known
about them and these are little tiny
tubes and I thought the chance of
preserving quantum coherence that level
was much much greater than in just the
last year or two a lot more people are
coming round to this idea because the
problem was always people said but can
you maintain quantum states in the brain
because the brain is a noisy messy and
warm place which is generally not good
for content to do anything with quantum
mechanics we we buy a truckload of
liquid nitrogen and freeze the entire
place down and then we start what we
they and some people didn't like it but
in the last two years a lot of new
people are starting because they've
realised actually they can find
disappearin quantum stuff in the brain
where they didn't expect it so so Rogers
detractors are all feeling bit peeved at
the moment
[Music]
you've written a lot or thought a lot
about quantum mechanics and a lot of
people see it as the most accurate it's
like giving the most accurate
predictions compared to other scientific
theories at the moment but your latest
what some of your latest work looks at
how quantum theory is actually a
misnomer would you be able to explain
this to us right so there's no doubt and
no one's going to dispute that there's a
mathematical formalism that we know how
to derive predictions from and those
predictions can be accurate to 14
decimal places but what a theory is what
a physical theory is is more than just a
mathematical formalism with some rules
it should specify a physical ontology
which means tell me what exists in the
physical world are there particles are
there fields is there space-time and
tell me about those things and then
specify some laws about how they behave
that tell me how they behave through
time and the problem is that there is
standard quantum what's taught as
quantum theory isn't isn't a theory in
that sense it's just the formalism and
then what people call interpreting
quantum theory which sounds like a funny
thing to do because you'd say well I
have a theory what's an interpretation
what's called interpreting quantum
theory is really the development of
precise physical theories that make the
same predictions or nearly the same
predictions that you get out of this
standard mathematical recipe and so this
to me clears up a kind of funny question
because often they say Oh a physicist
would say well I've got quantum theory
what do I need an interpretation for
what the philosophers do the
interpreting whatever that is and that's
because the language is misleading them
no you don't have a theory you have a
predictive recipe and what we want as a
physicist what you should want is a
theory is something that makes clear
statements about what the world is
so does that mean that actually quantum
mechanics is a lot stronger in its
predictions than the kind of public
broad audience thinks what does it mean
that they're not there yet and they
still need to work towards having the
stages of the theory well there are
different approaches that people have
been working on this is a very minority
group who work in foundations of physics
so there's a whole approach that goes
back actually to 1925 and Louis
debroglie that's called the pilot wave
theory there's another approach that are
called objective collapse theories and
Roger Penrose is working on those and
some other physicists Giancarlo Girardi
particularly it worked on versions of
objective collapse theories and these
are just different theories and they all
make the same predictions insofar as
they have been tested so far so we can't
go to into a lab and say which of these
approaches is right even though in
principle sometimes these different
approaches make slightly different
predictions you have to think very hard
about how you could actually test them
and what does quantum tell us about
physical reality well that's what's
interesting is that these different
approaches would give you different
answers so if you if I say well I think
it's the pilot wave approach is correct
I'm gonna say well it tells me that the
quantum mechanical wave function is not
a complete physical description and
maybe the world is deterministic and so
on and if I take an objective collapse
theories a that tells me the world is
fundamentally in deterministic and so
there's no single answer to that the one
thing we know for sure is that there's a
kind of nonlocality and this comes from
a theorem of john bell which doesn't
depend on the interpretation john donne
bell proved that just certain results
that you get in the lab cannot be
reproduced in a theory that is local in
a certain well-defined sense so there
has to be some non locality
where do you stand amongst these
theories I I mean I have a slight but
this is just my preference my my
aesthetic sense is that the pilot wave
approach seems more natural to me and
the objective collapse approach seems to
me more unnatural but I wouldn't you
know give a lot of attention to my
aesthetic preferences here they're both
very serious they're trying to write the
theory down in completely precise
mathematical terms and everybody should
pay attention to all the going things
that are actually out there that have a
chance of being right look around you
attentively what you see is not what is
there your sensorial apparatus is being
targeted by lots of different signals
from the environment and everything is
conspiring to creating a definite sharp
image of this room the light the color
position of chairs number of people they
all have a definite value all of these
properties and yet we know from physics
that this is not what is really there
all the particles in this room those
that compose your bodies the photons in
the light and there is other things
things that make sound propagate phonons
etc are all quantum mechanical particles
and that means that most of their
properties are not sharp are not
definite quantum mechanical particles
exist in states where if you wanted to
measure some of the properties of these
particles most of the times you would
get an answer of which you can only
predict the probability but
is uncertain is indefinite and for this
property I will use the word on
sharpness
this is unsharp Nisour quantum systems
and this is what actually gives the
appearance at the macro scale of these
definite features that we all can see so
let's take a look
classically what we know is that objects
have definite properties so for example
if you want to describe a neutron you
can for instance say that a neutron is
at a particular position zero or it's in
a different position one these two
positions are distinguishable you can
also assign an energy to the neutral and
lots of other properties spin etc and
they're all definite quantum
mechanically picture is completely
different there is a state where the
neutron is in position zero does it say
it where the neutron is in position one
but also there is this particular state
here which I represent pictorially like
that where we can only predict the
probability for the neutron to be in
position 0 or 1 but the position is
unsharp and these states are called
super positions and notice that these
unsharp ness has nothing to do whereas
very little to do with stochastic
uncertainty like when you throw a dice
this is a different type of and
sharpness is richer and this is why it's
the key property that powers all of
quantum mechanics features including
those that are used for quantum
computers for quantum cryptography and
for pop for properties like entanglement
there are extreme exotic and different
for what we perceive now this on
sharpness is mind-boggling it's a very
beautiful feature of these quantum
systems but it's also a source of very
interesting problems and one of the most
interesting problems comes up when we
try to us
cried the Sun sharpness two objects
which are demanded by other physical
theories to be sharp all the time and
this is the case of gravity now general
activity is this theory that Ison came
up with to describe masses and the way
they interact through gravitational
forces and relativity theory of
gravities in general have no on
sharpness they want their objects to be
all the time sharp in the position there
are energy all of their features so when
you want to describe for instance the
interaction between two masses like this
you can only describe this if you can
assume that these masses are fixed and
have definite positions and then they
interact with respect to one another
through gravitational interactions
general activity can take the young
sharpness of quantum theory so for
example what happens if instead of two
sharp masses in sharp positions you have
masses that are in quantum
superpositions of different locations so
quantum theory requires every object to
be capable of being in these super
positions so we have to consider these
States if we believe in quantum theory
but at the same time if we believe that
these are masses and that they can
gravitate they should also bei general
relativity but general activity doesn't
allow this type of states it can't deal
with this so there's a big question mark
there and physicists are scratching
their heads about this what is going on
how do we describe this
well we've for a long time we've we've
heard these stories about how quantum
mechanics is weird and how there is this
subatomic world of this atomic world
that obeys different rules to the ones
we're used to and we have stories that
we tell about that about how particles
could be in two places at once and how
they can mysteriously communicate to
each other over long distances and so on
and what I'm saying in my new book is
that we need to change those stories we
need to change the record really and
part of the reason to that is that the
the field hasn't Stood Still the the the
questions at the heart of it are the
same ones that people like Niels Bohr
and Albert Einstein were grappling with
when they invented this this quantum
mechanics but we know more now and
particularly we know more because some
of the experiments that were just
thought experiments in their day we can
now actually do with today's
technologies and have done and so we
have we don't necessarily have all the
answers about what quantum mechanics
means but we have much better questions
we've refined the questions and I think
this is shown us that these old ideas
about particles being in two places at
once or taking two paths at once or
whatever they're just our classical
attempts so you know using analogies
from our everyday world to try to
develop some language to explain what's
going on so I understand why we have
them but actually they're missing the
point the whole point about quantum
mechanics is that it's not practical
that particles don't in any obvious way
just take par through space or just are
here or there quantum mechanics is
counterintuitive in a very profound way
and we need new stories to grapple with
that and one of the ways I think we can
start to think about it more
productively is in terms of what is
knowable and what is not in terms of
information but in particular in terms
of the information that we have access
to although we don't have access to and
one of the productive ways that
physicists are now thinking about this
is in terms of perhaps there being some
imbalance between the kind
of questions we can ask about a quantum
mechanical system a particle or whatever
and the answers it can give us that it
can't actually at that quantum level the
world can't give us unambiguous answers
to every question we can ask and when it
doesn't you know what we seem to get
when we've sort of run out of answers
it's just randomness and the result of
that is that things look very strange
from our everyday point of view but we
need to sort of shift the thinking away
from how it usually works in science
where we think I'm going to interrogate
this system I'm going to ask a question
and I'll get a result in quantum
mechanics you don't always do that so
asking what is this particle like and
what is this particle like you you think
you should get two answers out of that
but in quantum mechanics it seems like
there are occasions many occasions in
fact where those two particles aren't
actually two particles they're kind of
the same thing even though they are
separated in space they're the kind you
have to think of them as a single entity
and so there's not enough information in
that single entity to give you answers
to those what seem like independent
questions because they're not
independent they're dependent on each
other
I think this it seems to be what's at
the heart of quantum mechanics so it's
really about what questions we can ask
and how much information we can expect
to get in response to those questions
have we already made some small steps in
that direction well at the moment and
the you know science has to do this and
does it all the time particularly the
frontiers of physics at the moment we
invent terms that patch over our
ignorant you know dark matter is a term
like that dark energy is a term and so
is we talk about in quantum mechanics
quantum nonlocality which basically
refers to this idea that you put it one
way the properties of a quantum object
aren't all located on that object some
of them might be kind of related to the
properties of some other odd
though those properties themselves are
smeared out as though you know the the
gold nurse of my ring is somehow not
just in my ring it's also in this other
object over here and we say that's
quantum nonlocality so there's word to
talk about it and it's useful to have
that word because it stops us then
saying well but it has to be in this
ring you know we say no it's non-local
so it's not you know it's somehow space
is is messed with here and sometimes
time is messed with in similar ways in
quantum mechanics but it's just a word
and you know we don't have an intuition
for it and you know we talked about that
also in terms of a property called
entanglement these two objects are
entangled together it's a nice
descriptive word what does it really
mean so at the moment we're at that
stage we can invent words that stop us
from telling these old stories or they
should stop us from doing that but they
don't really give us an intuition of
what's going on and I'm not at all sure
that we will get past that because of
this fact that of course our language is
the language that you have when you're 6
feet tall and you're living in a
classical world if we were electrons and
protons we would have a language to
describe these things but we're not
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you